welcome Walsman through - PewDiePie
channel if this is you farce clicking in
then it doesn't get better than this hey
how's it going bros my name is peter pan
welcome to where to stuff online
christmas is coming you need ideas for
gifts I'm here to help you out don't
worry
really stepped it up this week will
probably be one of the craziest items
that I've ever found item number one a
[ __ ] poop emoji face stain hilarious
Edgar likes to inspect like every
[ __ ] item that we have Jesus Christ
are you done you may think well they
ain't getting better than poop emoji
face but you're wrong
pickled lip balm flavored til all right
here we go oh you know what it's pretty
[ __ ] good that's the weirdest [ __ ]
thing it's really good Edgar you want
some yeah I'm sucking on pickles the
[ __ ] are you on about all right next
item is what's that a bonus iron bonus
item yeah a bonus item for me British
celebrity you grown from British
celebrity Hugh Grant q what do you have
for me
oh thanks Hugh okay what a weird bucks
now [ __ ] off
okay let's see what's inside it's a it's
a camel toe hider Oh all right let's try
it out
now you may have heard of this next item
it is called shreddies USA it's
basically someone invented underwear
that blocks out the scent of your farts
it can effectively filter odors 200
times the strength of the average flatus
emission it feels right like regular
underwear
it smells like regular underwear any
time I fart and girl loves to smell my
[ __ ] so what that's not true
let's just let's let him be the ultimate
judge oh my god I hope I don't [ __ ] my
pants I'm trying really hard to fart
trying to relax oh this is mouth
does it smell and yet answer me damn it
it works this changes everything
I gotta call someone all right so the
last I the way PewDiePie here and I'm
riding on the sponsor eagle you're
riding sponsor eagle is a Luke Wright
another lootcrate
send it to me thank you thank you so
much loot crate so for those of you who
don't know loot crate is a box that
sends to you every month a new theme of
awesome items now you may want to
consider subscribing to loot crate
because then we can open these together
and if you go to loot crate calm slash
pills
enter the code pills you get 10% off
you're welcome next month's theme is
this is pears from the future this
month's theme is combat and next month's
theme is galaxy you have to order before
the 19th to get bad box that's it for me
oh my god this is awesome already
shredder [ __ ] shades be
okay right away I see the volt boy thing
and right away I'm like [ __ ] yes oh [ __ ]
yes
favorite item that's so cool yes this
may the entire box is worth it
oh so this this is exclusive for Luke
right that's pretty awesome
mockingjay pin okay so Blizzard cute and
deadly I hope I get the merlok please be
the merlok all right what do we got
please smile a lot
I wanted the green merlok sorry Street
Street Fighter comic-book that ass and
that was it for this month's loot crate
if you enjoy getting a package every
month
everyone loves packages sign up for loot
crate I know what you're thinking he's a
handsome fella but delight Signet let's
move past the beautiful face and look
that there is more substance than just
that look at this last item roller wheel
100% rolling will you know you know how
much you know much it takes to keep
ordering a bunch of crap to your house
it's not easy let me just say what that
oh it comes with a pump thank [ __ ]
god for that I've blown a lot of [ __ ]
during this show
alright goddamnit this is huge in it oh
god [ __ ] me okay well I'll see you
browsing 84 years are you [ __ ] me
right now we vapid deep adapt now mo I
wouldn't do it alone marble
it's so tiny I thought it would be
Viggen please I need more pickle like
mom they'll do the trick oh it's better
be as cool as it was advertised cuz they
look at the box and look how happy that
girl is
how did the girl do it
I dare you want to try it come here come
on yellow [ __ ]
am I having the time of my life
absolutely absolutely that's it for five
weird stuff online if you enjoy this
show please continue to leave your
support we really appreciate it
and that helps us get more awesome stuff
for the for the videos don't forget to
check out loot crate it's down in the
description and that's all for now as
always stay awesome bros oh god oh
nightmares ah why am I keep doing this